okay I'm getting opening requests it's
hard to play openings when I'm not
playing a game though so let's accept
someone hey Siri where are you okay
Syria has abandoned me so I have to I
have to find a way to like get a random
number
hmm well it's 648 so we'll do number
four one two three four okay
casual game 5 +5 how something something
something is finally watching me live
well welcome how thanks for watching
so the openings that I was recommended I
can't like I can't play a reverse London
I can't play the Budapest I can't play
the Kings Indian everyone was suggesting
openings against e4 I need an opening
against e4 I'll just wait until someone
recommend something scan d okay scan D
is the closest thing to a reverse London
and I could play ooh French I kind of
would want to play but okay too late
playing a scandi I have a few students
who play the scan d4 black and I think
it's a reasonable opening it kind of
gets repetitive like a lot of my
students games are just there they're
entering the same structure and like
they get good at playing this sort of
structure but sometimes it gets I don't
know it's just redundant repetitive or
done no I mean I just feel I feel the
redundancy like being uh being created
from this opening in my speech okay I'm
gonna play Bishop g4 first and then e6
this is what I've taught my students
develop the bishop actively play e6 put
the bishop actively
g6 and then usually do the setup and
decide whether I want to Castle kingside
or queenside but the one thing I'll say
about like Scandinavian is that there's
more to chess and just playing these
sort of structures
I think first anyone who plays
Scandinavian consistently it's a good
opening for some time but then at some
point it helps to learn something beyond
the realms of these lines I like the
fact that he's committed to f3 seems a
little bit weakening maybe someday I'll
play c5 maybe you could play c5 right
away but no let's be patient I'll play
c6 because I just want to play Queen c7
Bishop d6 97 and then decide can i play
Queen atch Queen h4 on move - I don't
think so
there is a line though I I learned not
too long ago where Queen h4 I think on
move 3 it's really interesting sort of
opening trap anybody I'll show it if I
remember after this game ok so I don't
know if he has a threat but I'm scared
anyway so I like Queen c7 mmm Bishop f4
okay so I'm fine with trading bishops
like if we trade that I'm less cramped
okay so we trade so you're gonna play 94
I'll probably play 94 very soon got some
initiative I'll have to move the Queen
back probably to e7
I'm a bit underdeveloped white is like
almost fully developed now it's actually
a question do I take with the pond or
the Queen I feel like most people would
take with the Queen avoiding the double
pawns but double pawns can sometimes be
good if I take with the pawn play 97
Castle queenside then they use a G file
and try and attack it's a possibility
take with the Queen he plays 94 again
I'm gonna take with a pawn so make
things a bit imbalanced and objectively
this might be the wrong decision but I
just want to make the position sharp
I'm curious if he if he's gonna try and
take advantage of my failure to develop
quickly and maybe he'll go for something
like rookie 1 in d5 and try and explode
the center but he's going for a slightly
different plan which I don't know what
he's doing with this night just continue
developing there's a move I would like
to play at some point this move f5 but
that makes a bishop really sad so maybe
Knight b6 allows Knight c5 at some point
so f5 right away how sad is my bishop
it's pretty sad
Bishop f5 I mean doesn't feel right okay
I'll play Knight b6 no go away iTunes so
the thing about my mouse there's like a
there's a button on my mouse which like
opens iTunes and it's easy to
accidentally press just somehow program
the mouse to do something more useful
Bishop b3 so I could castle attack the D
pawn I'll probably defend with riff d1
let's do it just going along with
original plan I mean get the King here
and then someday use a G file I'm trying
to figure out like how the pieces can
start coordinating like I'm imagining
okay let's start with virtue a most
flexible imagining okay I could
potentially double up I can get the
bishop to maybe h3 and the night maybe
to f4 and then I could have potentially
four attackers against the Jeep on and
if he ever plays g3 I'll storm with h4
h5 h4 so the question here is how I want
to execute probably I should start with
Bishop f5 and he plays a five ninety
five a six b6 looks okay don't know if
I'm threatening Bishop h3 immediately
because he'll have night g3 no Bishop h3
night g3 I have a tricky move h5 and if
he takes I play h4 I should be happy
there
I mean I might just want to play 95 soon
- its 95 9 F 4 is a monster threat so
he's thinking which is good it's a sharp
position so thing about Scandinavian
like sometimes it's black who chooses
whether to make it sharp or positional
because almost always white castles King
side and then black chooses whether to
Castle queenside or king side okay so
he's going for a 5 I mean I don't think
it makes any sense for him to take the
Knights
unless he wants to get a worse position
and neither floor will come I'm
wondering like if he plays a 6 I might
already have mine at 4 or knife at 4
ok so he plays my g3 he wants to give me
triple pawns get rid of my bishop and I
play Knight f4 plays Queen e3 I play
Queen d6 looks reasonable there's a
funny idea which doesn't work at all I
was thinking if he ever moves in line I
have rook take g2 King takes you to
Knight f4 but he would have Queen take
g2 and time is running low so I should
probably move more quickly there's a
move I'm calculating here which might
make sense as Queen c7 might take out 5
9 f4 I think that's reasonable if he
takes on d5 I take with rook if you see
for Brooke take a 5 let's do that so I'm
trying to bait him into taking either my
knight or my bishop this could backfire
maybe I'm overlooking something but
it looks reasonable guess if he takes on
d5 all I have to take back with rook
there might be some cases where I might
just want to sacrifice get rid of the
knight or maybe just h5h for Queen c7
looks like hope chess I mean maybe I'm
hoping for him to blunder but I think
the Queen is just better placed on c7 -
I mean I target the pawn i target the
diagonal I get out of the pin and my
hopes and dreams came true I'm not sure
if White has a defense here but I'm
pretty sure this should turn out good
for black because rook take g2 is coming
or night take e2 is coming Queen f2 I
have night h3 this should take you six
just pawn to g6 so maybe he'll play
Queen e3 or that but then I just take on
g2 and I'll be up I'll have a queen for
wrecking bishop in the end anything
better guess I could take care of first
but that gets weird so let's take care
first
and okay I'll have triple pawns but I
have a queen I have an open G file -
life is good
have for fixing one paw in fixing three
ponds it's kind of sad but it's so happy
let's play rocky Yates I think the goal
is to put the rook on e4 and just target
f4 even if he plays rook e1 rookie four
will come
and now I could win a 5 if I want Oh
what to do he's passive I have time H
five just improve ooh I forgot about
that move I mean if I lose one of my
triple pawns it's not such a bad thing
I could take on a five - but let's not
give away the rook always play King b8y
a rookie 4 is a bad move there I still
have pressure I want to play Queen III
target the C pawn it's the only
undefended pawn that he has and you
can't really challenge the e-file
okay let's throw in a check this is a
type of move I'm not really calculating
I'm just assuming I check and maybe I
check here and maybe it should lead to
something or maybe not yeah it's just
leading to a trade probably should have
calculated that
he's gonna play rook f3 next what to do
it is not easy to win I mean the goal is
either to somehow when upon or make a
pass pong but I mean first I might have
to create a weakness or activate my king
I mean I'm still in good control I might
want to look to play ch4 at some points
if it works like a rock off three h4
could be some idea wow so he's just
giving me the pawn I was expecting
either rook c2 or workout three there
but now all I mean everything is falling
this is all attacks and he just resigns
well I was not expecting the game to end
and like one more move but okay his time
situation was bad to pawn demonium like
that have to keep that in mind for a
stream title in the future okay so that
was fun triple pawns not necessarily a
bad thing you have a queen and your
opponent doesn't yeah I was happy happy
with the position pieces came to life I
was not reading the chat too much people
were saying stuff I was trying to avoid
looking at suggestions I can program my
mouse buttons and customize on em
together round to that giant hello from
Columbia
hello Columbia Missouri or Columbia the
country dad man Geum is joining as like
just as I'm about to end things because
I'm hungry and I'm tired